[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté j'aime ce qui est devant nous
c'est frais c'est appétissant on s'est
mis qu'est-ce que vous avez l'intention
de nos fesses on va faire des tortillons
fruits de mer ou que ça va être bon
train et puis une tarte aux moules et au
coq où je vais aimer tous les deux je
crois vous si moi aussi leur après
l'autre et alors qu'est ce qu'il vous
faut pour ces deux recettes
il faut des vins blancs secs et voilà il
faut des petits tortillon alors les
tortillon on a fait attention il y en a
aux épines aisément
il y en a d'autres à l'atome à ratoma
pour un thomas somare déjà naturel voilà
comme vous et moi voilà ailleurs pour
lutter et bien ça y est en afrique il
faut décoder petit coq il faut des
moules il faut des coquilles
saint-jacques lui on a la chance d'avoir
frêche c'est encore mieux
c'est après il faut des sèche oui tout
préparé la voie la coupe et il faut du
basilic ça n'a pas du fruit d'un konami
du sec
parfois quand même il faut du temps il
faut de l'aïe
il faut du persil il faut des tomates et
puis c'est tout il va c'est bien joli
par quoi allons nous commencer par le
tortillon c'est bien la fée et nettoyer
les moules hélico il faut les médias oui
et ça il faut bien laver parce que du
sable
oui à plusieurs ou et comme il faut à
plusieurs qu'est ce que vous en faites
et bien écouteurs a commencé à cuire
alors là j'ai mis du beurre dans la
poêle
on en fait on y viendra après voilà dans
cette cocotte je vais monter beckham et
feu je vais y verser les coquettes
élégantes et les moules que vous les
ouvriers comme pour réouvrir hervé y
mettre du vin blanc sec sec ci ou ça
fait voilà vous à les couvrir et couvrir
et le temps qu'elle s'ouvre dans la
marmite d'arros et on va mettre quoi il
ne faut pas perdre de temps de l'eau
salée que j'ai déjà salée les torpilles
en tortillant torpillant torpille est
voilà au drapeau italien vert blanc
rouge c'est comme ça vous ne saviez pas
enfin je me rappelais plus l'aimer tout
allez-y on en réponse au soir ne ratez
pas la recette
ce cas sans ça on sera perdue là voilà
les torpilles en s'armant pas couvrir
est bon ensuite j'ai mis du beurre
oui qui va pas très fort pour être là
mettre un peu plus fort oui je vois que
ça brûle m'a fait pour sa superbe et
voilà j'aimais le rayon c'est pourquoi
pour les échos qui peut-être coquilles
saint jacques qui te vois les copies
vous les avez aussi bien nettoyer il
faut lui enlever la barbe voit la france
et surtout nous il ya du sable aussi il
faut bien les laver
il ya une icône les coquilles avec un
corail comme ça moi le meilleur cru
tellement c'était premier choix je vais
les mettre tout doucement
la voilà dans la poêle dans le beurre
je vais les saler poivrer voilà voyez on
fait tout un bâtard un quart mais mais
mais ça va sur la foule et ça va très
très vite à 30 secondes de chaque côté
mais lequel son nom restera parmi nos
ingrédients vous est sèche
voilà qu'on va faire après on les
apparaît comme dit élégamment maïté
c'est à dire qu'on a enlevé l'or au
milieu qu'on a donnée aux oiseaux vers
leur bec aux gaspillages
on a enlevé la poche d'encre sont à
crever parce que c'est très sale
même si ça fait une très bonne source
voilà c'est pas on nous apprenait on les
a les barbes et on enviait tentacules et
regardez le résultat des voix la
pétition c'est même plus de quel animal
ça sort qu'est ce que vous en faites
j'ai mis de l'huile dans une cocotte oui
je vais m'y mettre mais sèche de la
lanière la salle comme voilà salut moi
c'est toujours pareil mais bien de brive
et voilà mais ça ne va pas suffire
rolala nom alors je vais y mettre tous
les petits aromates c'est à dire je vais
y mettre le terme les branches adopté
comme elles sont fraîches les managers
que ça c'est bon ça va donner un bon
goût après je vais y mettre le mas
d'azil je cherche le nom sec mais on n'a
pas vu mais rim est un plus mais c'est
bon c'est bon quand même
du moment que ça que c'est bon il ya là
un people de puces tient là sa soeur
jusqu'à mon nez
la ion indien après vous mettez pas
non je vais mettre le persil voyez
grossièrement en peluche blanche est là
et je vais y mettre l'eau à l'eau des
commentaires que vous deviendrez et on
va laisser cuire ça une bonne demi heure
là surtout people en laisse voilà et on
laisse mijoter 5 demi heure et ensuite
on verra ce qui se passe avec les new
l'étendre à convoquer une âge que sa
cuisine
maintenant vous m'avez guînes aussi mais
pas dans l'eau pas simplement vos
particulier heureusement ma hippiques
vous vous en êtes où vous attend
mahler toujours si nos mémoires voilà
parce que tout va il aurait brûlé
voilà et on va laisser mijoter sagesse
et le feu une demi heure
naucelle ont changé d'aspect après une
demi heure 1 5 8
elles sont comme il faut là où il faut
alors qu'est ce que vous allez rajouter
on a des coquilles et le goc et les
coques et limoux lequel était très jolie
d'ailleurs les petites aux plus de
google os et on a dû réduire nos potes
mri et qu'est ce que vous faites le
népal où je vais mélanger
cet enfant de terrain je pense que
toutes les m parce qu'elle leur offre un
peu trop sa serai un peu trop parce
qu'en moto2 quand même il faut pas
exagérer la bonne appétit mais je crois
que pour inviter la famille avait ce que
vous avez mis là après pour échauffer
parce que c'est froid ça oui alors c'est
simple
voilà et ça va ensemble
mélangez un petit salon wii sans rien
ajouter de plus là en tout y en mélange
le tout on recouvre cinq minutes et on
sert à table
non parce que vous avez oublié les
copies c'est vrai à les poser vers si
micheline c'est bien alors à ses belles
coquilles saint jacques avec leurs
études parce qu'il n'y a pas grande
chose
oh là là mon dieu voilà le meilleur le
meilleur que jamais oublier
là on va le laisser chauffer sert
minutes et enfin on va passer à table
tout de suite mais nous nous avons
encore quelque chose à faire c'est la
seconde recette c'est la tarte aux
moules et au coq j'ai étalé la pâte dans
un moule très bien vous les voyez comme
il faut à la fourchette
et qu'est ce qu'un bon gré dit là-bas
alors là j'ai fait revenir de l'oignon
oui et là je fais quelques petits
lardons ou doucement il faut toujours
améliorer l'ordinaire et on va bien sûr
on aurait pu faire ça mais ça ça va pas
gâcher maintenant layana vigueur il est
tout petit il a oui et 5 juan de
déconner oui les adéquat né voilà on va
faire cuire tout ça pendant que ça finit
de cuir je vais mettre sur ma part un
tout petit peu de coulis de tomates que
j'ai fait et oui ça il faut qu'il soit
on ne veut pas la boîte animée par et ce
n'est pas l'affairé du frais que vous
avez fait vous même voilà alors ça ça
cuit je vais y mettre un tout petit peu
de coulis parce qu'on les fait vous
l'avez fait comment vous avez fait
réduire de l'atome est très longtemps
est un type de lauriers de temps face
comme à l'habitude les épisodes assez
bien évidemment au foyer bien rouge et
décoratif ou de coulis ouais il a fait
ça en été quand les tomates sont bien
mûr il a bien au bon goût tient toujours
la voilà tu es un petit peu plus tard au
diable l'avarice
voilà alors ménard dont toute façon ça
va parce que ils vont finir de cuire
dans la tarte là en remettra tomates
alors la tomate fraîche parcours qu'on
aa chez paco pena parfait voilà pourquoi
et on va refaire écrire tout ça pour
vous ce mot n'est peut-être saler
poivrer un peu parce que la tomate a
toujours besoin et on va y rajouter on
espère un petit peu là et on va y
rajouter un petit peu de basilic ce on
va du basilic on l'as roma en sec
aujourd'hui
oui mais voilà on va laisser mijoter
tout ça une dizaine de minutes
or la barre voilà
ne s'enfuira maïté une belle fumer ça
bien réduit ça une bonne consistance
jolis seins mais moi je trouve aussi
appétissant qu'est ce que vous faites
maintenant
alors maintenant on va carrément vive et
tout ça sur cette tarte
voilà
et puis où c'est bon ça sent bon ce
avant ça fait dix ans que oui oui oui
d'une belle entrée ça même avec une
salade un peu de résistance
alors je vais y remettre par dessus
voile à l'école et les vous je vais
faire à la main pour que ce soit bien
des coquilles et bien si j'ai n'égalise
et on peut bien travailler copier mais
les complices un portail est l'écho qui
sait les paupiettes c'est décoratif ça
serait rendu à genre voilà mes fautes et
nous aussi bon comme certains aiment à
le pratiquer le bruit tiens voilà à
n'est pas moralement on va falloir
mettre ça dans un fils qu'on a chauffé
au moins un quart d'heure avant et on
avale n'y a plus que la pâte à faire
cuire et alors vers laval 20 minutes
voilà très bien mérité vous le mettez
dans notre fou et bien on va mettre à
cuire à faire 25 minutes et voilà notre
superbe tarte aux moules et au coq
salaires l'appétissante n'était plus
qu'un petit centre et appétissante et
les bonnes âmes envie de croquer je
voulais vous dire
et puis alors là et là c'est pareil avec
ce sont les avions façon délicieux et
que ces bâtisses facile comme tout on a
tous ces dépenses là les petits
tortillant de toutes les couleurs oui
des coques des moules pareil et les
coquilles saint-jacques à 38 juste à
point poser dessus que c'est fait 5 5
minutes de torture c'est tout vous voyez
la cuisine cette affaire d'imagination
parce que voilà des recettes très
simples qu'on vous a montré et selon les
produits que vous avez autour de vous
vous pourrez imaginer autre chose
world autre idée sur cette base de
recettes faire quelque chose d'un peu
différent
et puis si vous avez 10 idée
merveilleuse pourquoi pas nous les
suggérer que nous serions pas les seuls
à vous donner des idées même si il y à
fond grand plaisir alors ce pas mais on
arrive à courir il faut nous en donne un
petit peu parce qu'on arrive au bout
bientôt oui mais non on aura encore des
autres idées alors au revoir et à
bientôt
bon appétit et merci
[Musique]